we've already learned that when we
multiply by ten let's say we took the
number at 53 and we were to multiply it
by ten it has the effect of shifting all
the digits one place to the left so this
should be a review for you but this was
going to be 530 and we could see that
what used to be in the tens place has
been shifted to the left to the hundreds
place and what used to be in the ones
place has been shifted to the left to
the tens place now and we saw if you
divide by ten you have the opposite
effect and so let's say if I had 120 I
could say that let's divide by ten I
could also say this is the same thing as
120 times 1/10 what is going to happen
there well in this situation all the
digits are going to shift one place to
the right so what used to be in the tens
place will now be in the ones place what
used to be in the hundreds place will
now be in the tens place so this is just
going to be equal to 12 so that was all
review but now we're going to extend
this a little bit by thinking about
things that have place values
representing less than a 1 I guess you
could say or we're gonna deal with
decimals so just to get ourselves warmed
up let's see if we could figure out what
3 point 0 1 5 times 10 is pause this
video and see if you can figure that out
well the exact same thing is going to
happen all of our digits are going to
shift one place to the left so right now
we have a 3 in the ones place we have a
0 in the tenths place we have a 1 in the
hundredths place and we have a 5 in the
thousands thousands place but now
they're all going to shift one place to
the left so the 3 is now going to go
into the tens place it's going to shift
one place to the left so we're going to
have in the tens place we're now going
to have our three and now this zero
which was in the tenths place is now
going to shift into the ones place so
zero is going to go right over the zero
is going to go right over there that is
now in the ones place and then we'll put
our decimal and now what's going to go
into the tenths place and the hundredths
place and actually I'll rewrite the
thousands place as well this one is
going to shift one place to the left
into the tenths place so into the tenths
place and then the five that was in the
thousands place is now going to shift
one place to the left into the
hundredths place so into the hundreds
place just like that now we could put a
trailing zero over here but that's not
going to change the value of this number
so I'll just leave it like that and so
there you have it we see that every
digit has shifted one place to the left
so this is equal to thirty point one
five I'll just put that zero there for
kicks and so we could think about the
other way around what if I were to take
sixty seven point five and if I were to
divide it by ten or five another way of
thinking about it is if I were to
multiply this by one-tenth pause the
video and see if you can figure out what
that's going to be well now every digit
is going to shift one place to the right
so the six is going to be in the ones
place the seven is going to go into the
tenths place and then the five is going
to go into the hundredths place so let's
write that out so our six is going to go
into the ones place and then we're going
to have our decimal point our seven is
going to go into the tenths place and
then our five is going to go into the
hundredths place so there you have it we
get six point seven five